There are a lot of myths about the
Council of Nika. One myth that you'll
hear sometimes is that that's where the
Christians decided what books would be
in the Bible. And that's not true. The
uh compilation of the Bible had nothing
to do with the Council of Nika. Uh there
are some who say that Constantine, the
emperor who convened the council, used
it as an opportunity to force his own
beliefs onto the Christians. Uh that's
also not true. He did not force his
beliefs on the Christians. He couldn't
care less what the Christians decided at
the council of Nika as long as they
decided something. Um, another myth that
you'll hear is that at the council of
Nika, the Christians invented a new
belief that they had not previously had
like the idea that Jesus is God or the
idea of the trinity. But both of those
things clearly predate the Council of
Nika. We see that in in the historical
record.
There is another um misconception out
there about the council that I want to
address in this video and that is the
idea that it was to put it in blunt
terms that it was that it was
historically sign significant. A lot of
people think that it was this major
historical event. In in a way it was and
I'll explain what I mean by that but it
was not a historically significant event
in the way that most people assume
because I think in the popular
imagination and often also the way it's
presented in textbooks and in lectures
and classrooms
uh there was this dispute going on
because the main thing that they talked
about at the council of Nika that gets
the attention was um that gets people's
attention is the um theological dispute
over the ideas of Aras.
Uh so the the the the typical narrative
goes there was this this dispute going
on
um and over the nature of Jesus
and uh the dispute was taken to the
council of Nika. The council of Nika
decided in a certain way against Aras
and then after that the Christians were
nine. They had the nyine creed and they
believed in, you know, the nyine uh side
of the debate and that was the end of
Aras. But in reality that was not
anywhere near the end of Aras. The story
does not end at 3:25. And if you were
alive in the 300s of the Roman Empire,
watching all these things all the all of
these things unfold, you would not have
thought at the time, oh wow, 325 was
this decisive threshold, this decisive
watershed moment. Like if you're in the
year 340 for example or 350, you would
not look back and be like, well 325, the
Council of Na, that was this huge
watershed moment that really changed the
course of Christian history. Um, not at
all. You wouldn't have thought that. All
right, but let's back up a minute and um
let me go over what happened with the
Council of Nika and what that all was
about. Um, and then maybe I could
explain what I mean um after that. So
the council of Nika was uh called in the
year 325
and it had several things that it was
going to address. It addressed some
disciplinary matters regarding rules for
example regarding clergy or regarding
how to treat Christians who had
compromised the faith during the
persecutions because this is right after
a period of really heavy persecution in
the early 300s. And then there was an
issue regarding how to calculate the
date of Easter because at the time some
Christians calculated Easter in such a
way that it could fall on any day of the
week. And other Christians calculated
Easter in such a way that it always had
to fall on a Sunday. And what that meant
was some Christians were celebrating
Easter on a different day than other
Christians. And so you'd have some
Christians who were still fasting, doing
the pre-Easter fast while other
Christians were already
celebrating Easter and feasting.
Um, and so that was regarded as a bit of
a problem. So they they wanted to get
some uniformity on that across uh the
Christian world, at least within the
empire. And then the other issue, the
really famous issue was what to do about
a particular priest in Alexandria named
Aras.
and the ideas that he was promoting and
this is probably the most famous aspect
of the council of Nika is is this issue
regarding areas.
Now what happened was in the city of
Alexandria
a dispute arose between the bishop
Alexander and one of his priests named
Aras. Bishop Alexander said that Jesus
aka the son of God or God the son
was eternal in the same way that God the
father is that Jesus or God the son has
always existed just as God the father
has always existed.
Aras objected to that and said that no
there was a time when Jesus did not
exist. Jesus in his pre-incarnate form
as the son of God or the God the son.
God the son did not always exist. There
was a time like ontologically, if
nothing else, ontologically the father
came first in such a way that he was not
originally a father, but then he
begat in some for in some sense begat
the son
and then
in in in so doing he became the father
and then the son was the son. Um, and
then through the sun, God created
uh the heavens and the earth, the
universe, time and space. I'm I'm being
a little bit weird about the way I'm
phrasing this because as far as I
understand, he believed that Jesus was
created prior to the creation of time.
So, he was created in an atmporal,
you know, like there was no time yet.
So, you can't really talk about him
being created before something else. I
mean, he was created in the sense he was
created before time. I guess you could
say that.
Um, and then the dispute that like
Alexander was saying, no, Jesus had
always been there. There was never a
time when Jesus wasn't Well, time again.
I It's kind of weird to use the word
time when neither. Anyway, I it okay,
sorry. Um, it gets a little bit nuanced.
Um, and actually speaking to this,
I've heard people say that when they're
lecturing on this topic or, you know,
making a video on this or something and
they'll talk about the difference
between the Aryan position and
Alexander's position and they'll say,
well, this sounds very complex or
abstract or whatever to the modern ear,
to a modern audience, but to people in
the 4th century, this was significant.
I disagree with that. I don't think it's
a matter of what century you live in.
That's not the issue. Becau actually
because um
uh who is it? Constantine. Constantine
was the emperor. This was going on this
this conflict between the two sides had
been going on for several years when
when Constantine showed up in the
eastern part of the empire. And when he
came and he you know he defeated
Lysinius and became the sole emperor of
the entire empire.
Um, so he shows up and there's this
dispute going on in the eastern part of
the empire among the bishops there
and they explained it to him. They
explained what the issue was and he did
not understand and he there's a letter
that's preserved in Ucius Cesaria's life
of Constantine where he he tells both
Alexander and Aras, both of you were out
of line. Alexander, you shouldn't have
been teaching that. Aras, you shouldn't
have disagreed with your bishop. There's
no reason. Constantine said, there's no
reason you should even be talking about
this stuff cuz it's so abstract and so
far away from real life. It's like it's
so like who cares? That was that was
Constantine's view. Who cares who like
like this barely a difference between
these two sides. So this is a man who
lived in the 4th century. So it's not a
matter about what century you live in.
The issue was Constantine was a a career
military man. He was not an
intellectual,
certainly not a theologian. And he
really did not care which side won or
you know who who prevailed or whose
opinion prevailed. He just wanted unity.
He wanted the bishops to be unified.
And so if if the Aryan position was
going to win out, that would be fine
with him as long as all the bishops go
along with it. If the anti-Aryan
position, I guess at this point, I don't
know what else to call it. If the
anti-Aryan position, the trinitarian
position, you could say the trinitarian
position. If that won out, Constantine
would be fine with that too. This goes
back to what I said at the beginning
about the myth that Constantine used the
council as an opportunity to force his
own beliefs on the bishops is really
silly when you look at the the
historical evidence like he is the exact
opposite. He did not care. Um, and it's
not just Constantine. One of our uh
sources, one of our main primary sources
for the events of the 4th century church
uh was um um a historian named Socrates
Scholasticus. So not the same Socrates,
it's the famous one that Plato talked
about. is a different guy named
Socrates.
But he also has a quote where he says um
where he's, you know, kind of talking
about this debate and he has this little
passage where he says um I I don't know
exactly I don't remember exactly how he
phrased it, but he's like both sides
believed that
the go the God the Father and God the
Son are distinct. Both sides believed in
the Trinity,
but for some reason they were fighting
anyway. and he basically says he doesn't
understand what the what the point of
the dispute was. Now, he was also not a
theologian.
So, he was not really steeped in
theology or scripture or any of those
things. This dispute was meaningful to
people in the clergy, people who were,
you know, they were bishops primarily,
but also priests and, you know, other
clergy. they were the ones involved in
the dispute and really engaged in it and
saw it as significant because they could
see the nuances and they felt that the
nuances were really significant.
So when this dispute arose in Alexandria
sometime probably in the late 310s we
don't know exactly when but maybe around
318 or 319
Aras ended up being exiled from the
dascese. So he left and he went to
Palestine
and started writing to different bishops
and enlisting them to support his side
of the dispute. So the dispute widened
out beyond Egypt into other parts of the
Eastern Roman Empire.
Meanwhile,
Constantine conquered the eastern part
of the empire from Lysinius.
And when he arrived, he found this
dispute happening among the bishops. And
so he called the council of Nika in
order for them to all get together and
hash it out and arrive at a decision
about what they were going to, you know,
what what was the one uniform position
they were all going to take. Now, this
was not the first council in church
history. There was plenty of precedent
for having a council. The Christian
bishops have been having councils for
centuries. But this was notable at the
time because this was the first time
when bishops from all over the Roman
Empire were called to come gather
together at one time. We don't know
exactly how many bishops attended. Uh
different sources give different
numbers, but it was probably somewhere
around 250 to 300 bishops, maybe a
little over 300.
And um they discussed a variety of
matters. As I said, um, and when it came
to discussing the Aryan issue,
they ended up voting overwhelmingly in
favor of Alexander's position, the the
Nyine position that Jesus is co-eternal
with the father.
And uh, they promulgated a creed, which
we call in retrospect the nine creed.
And that again was not a new thing.
There had been creeds before. Um it was
simply a statement of faith that they
were all supposed to sign and agree to.
Now it was not exactly in the same form
that the modern nying creed is because
there was a later council in 381 called
first council of Constantinople that
augmented it a little bit. But basically
the the the point at issue was a single
word in the Greek and that was the word
homosion which means um well it's
typically translated into English as
consubstantial but you can also
translate it as of the same substance or
of the same essence. Uh so it was
describing the father. It was you know
there's this long clause in the in the
nyine creed that talks about Jesus and
the nature of Jesus what he was you know
God from God light from light etc. And
then there's this line where where it
says u conssubstantial with the father
or one in being with the father you know
it can be translated in different ways.
So that that phrase one and being in
Greek is homosion. That was the sticking
point for the Aryan party because that
was the part that sounded like
seellionism to them.
So most of the bishops ended up agreeing
to that formula to that creed as it was
drafted.
But there were a handful of bishops that
did not. We don't know the exact number
of bishops as far as I know cuz I I in
my research I felt like I was seeing
different numbers and l you know there
would be a handful of bishops that that
objected. I don't know exactly how many
um but notably
in addition to Aras
uh it was the bishop of Nicodemia Ucius
and the bishop of Nika the Agnes
and all three of them and some other you
know handful of bishops were exiled
because they refused to sign the Nying
creed
and so like typically That's where the
story ends. And the way when when people
are telling the story of the council of
Nika and the Aryan controversy, that's
where they stop. They're like, "Okay,
they held the council. They decided on
the nine creed. They included the
Homusion
and they exiled all the people who
rejected it."
Um but that's not at all where the story
ends because uh within a couple years in
3:27
all three of those individuals came back
from exile and were reinstated. Um of
Nicodemia, Theognus of Nika and Aras of
Alexandria.
Aras
uh he wrote a letter to uh Constantine
and he included a statement of faith a
creed that he wrote out I believe in
blah blah blah blah blah and he wrote
out basically the nine creed but he left
the humusion out
but Constantine said that's good enough
for me and so he let Aras come back and
and he wrote a letter to Alexandria and
said uh Bishop Alexander you need to
reinstate Aras as a priest. Well, Aras
shows up and Alexander, you know,
realizes Aras is not repentant. He still
believes that Jesus is subordinate to
the father and create a creature of the
father. So, he says, "No, you can't be a
priest here." Um, and this starts a
really long period of decades
of bishops continuing to fight over this
issue.
So, the the the fighting didn't end in
325.
That was really just the beginning near
the beginning. It went on for decades
after that where some of the bishops
took the nyine position. Some of the
bishops took the Aryan position and they
kept arguing with each other. Now they
knew that Constantine and then he had a
successor Constant his son Constantius
II
who was similar to his father in that he
did not care which side prevailed. He
just wanted there to be unity among the
bishops.
um they knew that the emperor was not
going to put up with
like out and out arguing and you know
creating division in the church but they
engaged in political maneuvering to
tarnish Alexander's name and then
Alexander's successor and Alexandria was
Athanasius they kept trying to slander
him and make him look bad and depose him
from office in order to get an a a an
Aryan placed in the position of bishop
of Alexandria.
So there was all this political
maneuvering behind the scenes and
because of Ucius and Mikimedia's close
association with Constantine, he was
able to use that close association to
advance the Aryan position. Um and it
was actually uh you know Constantine
famously was baptized on his deathbed.
It was of Nicodemia the Aryan who
baptized him. And then during the 4th
century, there were tons of councils
being held. I mean, there were councils
being held anyway because that was the
normal way of doing business um on a
kind of macro level in the church. You'd
have bishops gather together from
different parts of a province uh to
discuss issues of mutual interest. Uh
and in fact, one of the canons of the
council of Nika said that bishops should
meet regularly to discuss issues.
Uh so there were tons of councils in the
4th century but then there were also
councils being called specifically for
the purpose of deciding the disputes uh
deciding the dispute between Aryanism
and and
um nineism I guess you could call it and
um the Aryans actually got the upper
hand and in most of those councils where
they discussed those issues the Aryan
position was the one that was adopted
either Aryanism or semiaranism.
Semi-aranism was a compromised position
where um you know the nyines said that
the father and the son are of the same
essence. Aras had said the father and
the son are of different essences. And
then the semi-aran position was that the
father and the son are of similar
essences. So still technically different
but very similar to each other.
uh and in Greek the difference between
the two terms was one letter. So the
nine position was homosios
and the semi-airan position was homoios.
There was an extra i in there because it
was um similar essence versus the same
essence.
Um, so, uh, if you were in the position
in the 300s
of seeing all this stuff play out, you
would not have thought to yourself, wow,
325, Council of Nika, that was the
really decisive point in which things
changed because there were other
councils, council of Ty, Council of
Serium, multiple councils of Serium,
Sardica, Councils of Antioch, Council of
Arimeum and Seucia, and on and on and
on. And there were all these councils
being held that you where usually the
Aryans and the semi-arans had the upper
hand. Things finally changed in 380. So
up until 380
there was a succession of emperors who
were all um nominally Christian except
for Julian who of course famously
rejected Christianity. So he's referred
to as Julian the apostate. But there was
a succession of emperors who while most
of them were nominally Christian, none
of them cared about which you know which
version of Christianity was true. They
just wanted the bishops to agree with
each other and come up to some come up
with some solution which is why the
semi-aran position was attractive to
someone like Constantius II because it's
like well that's a compromise like you
guys are compromising. Isn't that the
point? Let's all compromise on this one.
So, um, anyway, up until 380, the
emperors didn't really care. But in
practice,
since the Aryan and semi-aran positions
were the ones that were predominant in
the eastern part of the empire, that was
the one that the emperors were pushing.
Uh, so in effect, it it meant that the
nyine bishops ended up getting um
mishandled sometimes. like Athanasius
for example, bishop of Alexandria was
exiled on five separate occasions
uh through the political machinations of
the Aryan party.
Now meanwhile in the western part of the
empire the bishops were all settled on
the nyine position and there wasn't a
lot of controversy happening in the emp
in in in that part of the empire. This
was really focused on the eastern part
of the empire.
So anyway, it all changed in 380 when
Theodocious came to the throne because
for the first time he was a a Christian
emperor who actually cared about the
matter and took a stand theologically
and he was a committed nyine Christian.
So when he came to power he favored the
nyine party and um suppressed the Aryan
party within the empire and he called
the council of Constantinople which in
retrospect is referred to as the first
council of Constantinople which convened
in 381 that reaffirmed the decision of
the council of Nika reaffirmed the creed
that came out of the council of Nika and
then augmented it a little bit added
some stuff at the end about the holy
spirit because in the meantime during
the 300s there had been another
Christian group that had arose arisen
called the Macedonians because they were
followers of a guy named Macedonius also
known as the Numatici
who believed that the Holy Spirit is not
God. So they didn't believe in a triad
but rather a diad like father and son
but not spirit. So uh in order to um you
know show that they were rejecting that
idea they included some stuff at the end
about the Holy Spirit. Um, but it's
still referred to as the nyine creed,
although technically you could call it
the Nino Constantinopolitan Creed.
That's a lot of syllables.
So, in what respect then can we say that
the Council of Nika was historically
significant?
I I I would say you could regard it as
historically significant in the sense
like for like in a couple different
ways. First of all, for the participants
in the council itself, for the actual
bishops who went to Nika in 325, for
them it was significant
uh symbolically
because this was the first time that a
church council was being convened by a
Roman emperor who was himself a
Christian.
And that in itself was highly
significant, highly symbolic.
And and then on top of that,
the fact that this was coming on the
heels of an extended period of really
brutal persecution of the church at the
hands of Roman emperors. And this is
partly why it was so significant that a
Roman emperor was convening this council
and ceremonially presiding over it. I
mean when people say that he presided
over the council of Nika, it doesn't
mean that he was injecting himself into
the debates or anything. It was more of
a ceremonial role. But um uh but anyway
the the you know his predecessors in the
eastern part of the empire had been
brutally suppressing Christianity for
several decades prior to Nika
and uh there were periods during that
time when the bishops had to go into
hiding and normal Christian worship was
disrupted
and um and some Christians were tortured
and killed. And so you had these bishops
convening at Nika and in many cases they
had been maimed during the persecutions.
There's one anecdote that's related.
There was a bishop in upper Egypt named
Pphanius who had had his eye gouged out
during the persecutions.
Then he was one of the attendees of the
council of Nika
and the emperor Constantine came over
and kissed his empty eye socket as you
know obviously paying homage to the
sacrifice that this Christian had
endured. But the fact there was a Roman
emperor doing that after all these years
a Roman emperors being enemies of the
Christians. Here's a Roman emperor doing
that. So it was very moving for the
participants of the council of Nika. For
them this event was very significant
just the but but not not based on what
decisions they were arriving at but just
based on the fact that you have a church
council calling bishops from all over
the empire under the presidency under
the presiding of a Christian emperor.
That was a big deal. So in that sense
you could say it was significant in a
symbolic way. It was marking a new era
in um the history of Christianity
because it was now transitioning from
being a persecuted minority to a
politically powerful minority. It was
still a minority but they now were in a
position of political power. Um so
there's that.
Um there is another respect in which you
can regard the council of Nika as
historically significant and that is
within the context of nine Christianity.
So for modern-day
Eastern Orthodox, Oriental Orthodox,
Catholics, and traditional Protestants
like Lutheran, um, uh, Presbyterians,
Reformed, um,
uh, Anglicans, for for those Christians
today, they look back at the Council of
Nika as important because that was when,
uh, the Ning Creed was written, which
was an important, historically important
articulation of their belief as
Christians.
Um, so it's significant from that point
of view. Certainly during the 3rd cent
during the 300s, during the 4th century
when these controversies were raging in
the eastern empire and people were
arguing back and forth,
those in the Nyine camp did always
hearken back to the council of Nika.
They would point back to the council of
Nika and say that was the correct
articulation of the faith. So for them
they were holding on to the council of
Nika but obviously the um you know the
Aryans
you know like the council of Nika wasn't
important for them they regarded it as a
wrong council.
So if you know if we were to imagine
some hypothetical scenario in which the
the Aryan version of Christianity
becomes the predominant version and the
mainstream version
they would not look back to the council
of Nika as being an important council.
they'd look back to some other council
from the 300s probably like Cermium a
357 something like that but the the
respect in which we cannot really say
that the council of Nika was
historically significant was that we
can't say that it was significant in the
sense that that was the watershed moment
at which Christianity took a new turn
where the Christian population or the
Christian community or or Christian
beliefs or whatever that's when things
dramatically changed
uh because it really wasn't. You know,
Aryanism continued on. It wasn't the
ending of Aryanism. Aryanism continued
on for decades within the empire. And
then even after 380 when Theodocious
cracked down on the Aryans, it pretty
much went away within the Roman Empire.
But then it was being spread uh among
the Germanic tribes in Europe. Um like
Ulis for example
who was a prominent Aryan during the 4th
century was also a missionary to the
Germans.
And uh so the Germanic tribes when they
converted to Christianity they converted
to the Aryan version of Christianity.
And then when they conquered the western
part of the empire and set up their
Germanic kingdoms in the fifth and sixth
centuries, they they were Aryans, but
they were an Aryan ruling elite ruling
over a predominantly Catholic population
because like I said uh sorry uh Nyine
population because like I said the um
um the western part of the empire had
remained in the Nyine camp for the most
part during the 4th century and that was
the part of the empire that the Germanic
tribes conquered.
So they were um they were ruling over
people who had different Christian
beliefs from themselves and it was
gradually over time over the succeeding
centuries of those Germanic tribes those
ruling elites I should say that were
Aryan converted to Christian converted
to nine Christianity. All right. So, let
me know if that was way too complicated
or like I mean I I I kind of wondered
when I was when I decided to do this
video. I I decided to do the video
because um I'm recording this in 2025
and I realized a few weeks ago, oh,
that's the,
you know, 1700th anniversary of the
Council of Nika in 325. And I'm kind of
a sucker for that kind of thing. So, I
couldn't resist making a video about
this. Um, if there's a famous event that
happened in a year ending in 26, I'm
probably going to do it next year. I
don't know. Um, anyway, um, I I I had
this idea of making this video and then
and then I was like, oh, this theology
stuff gets kind of complicated. I don't
know. I don't know if it's going to work
in a video format. But so, let me know
if it worked. Um, but yeah, so anyway,
thanks for watching and have a good one.